pour amadou cette job barry auteur et
chercheur ces élections vont permettre à
la majorité présidentielle de mesurer sa
popularité
écoutez on peut dire que ces élections
locales sont des élections de textes en
fin de test pour la majorité
présidentielle
parce qu'il s'agit en effet aussi pour
elle de vérifier son ancrage au sein des
collectivités et des localités au
sénégal entre autres dakar qui en fait
qui est la ville la plus importante où
se trouve 40% de la torah nationale et
avec tout ce qui s'est passé à mars 2020
dans la sphère sonko qui a fragilisé les
relations sociales au sénégal et qui
apportaient une parti d'opposition a
accusé
un concours de gouvernance macky sall je
pense que il y a leurs élections locales
un test aussi en prévision des élections
législatives dans quelques mois et
surtout de la présidentielle du 24 mai
c'est aussi me semble t'il un test aussi
pour l'opposition dans la mesure où elle
aussi elle est censée vérifier sa force
sur le champ politique sénégalais et
surtout pour se positionner là besoin de
savoir quel est le rapport de confiance
que les collectivités entretiennent avec
les forces de l'opposition